from the moment I talked to Sam about  the idea as a one-shot movie I knew it  was gonna be really immersive it's meant  to make you feel that you are in the  trenches with those young men the camera  never comes away from the two characters  [Music]  sometimes you have a camera being  carried by an operator hooked onto a  wire that the wire carries it across  more land it's unhooked again that  operator runs with it then steps onto a  small Jeep which carries him another  four hundred yards and he steps off it  again and goes around a corner the dance  of the camera and the mechanics all have  to be in sync with what the actors doing  when you achieve that it's really  beautiful and exhilarating